so I am asking people about cleaner
games and how they would survive and I
want to know what your tactic is for
surviving the Hunger Games uh Wow I
don't think I would survive I would die
first
I'd die within an instant I would not
survive I'm not a survivor I just asked
them to kill me immediately
so dark then you ask them to kill you I
feel like just end my misery now can I
just stay in one place and wait for
everyone else to die
you know what weapon you would use
Knight crossbow which is cooler than a
regular bow my weapon would be
friendship I would have a bag of
doughnuts with me smuggle that in your
purse what weapon would you use to
defend yourself I get LASIK because you
break your glasses or you lose a contact
like you're screwed I would say I would
hide just hi I'm pretty good at hiding
really good at hiding I would take cow
manure and hey get on to myself and then
I would hide they're all hiding that but
I'm gonna light flares and start a
bonfire and get everybody into one arena
I'm gonna forge an alliance with you and
then I'll just give a harpoon into your
back and eat your body but you know you
told me that so that's not going to work
the son of a do you have a tactic for
surviving uh stick with Jennifer
Lawrence she always seems to win that
wondering how grumpy cat would survive
other games
I'm trying to gauge her mood right now I
think she hates us all equally